Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est bientôt la fin.
Oui c'est bientôt la fin du jeu des énigmes et avec 1 énigme par jour pendant les 32 jours.
J'espère que vous avez kiffé ce jeu cet été. Moi j'ai vraiment trippé à mettre tout ça en place.
Et comme ces vidéos ont été faites en avance, ça veut dire que là en ce moment,
je suis en train de carburer à mort pour vous préparer les nouvelles vidéos qui vont reprendre.
Bref ! Avant de vous donner l'énigme d'aujourd'hui, la réponse de l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, regardez la vidéo d'hier, pour comprendre l'énigme avant de connaitre la réponse.
Donc la réponse est que Menthe est un Mental et Team et Alo font parti de la tribu Vlog.
Ce que dit Alo ne peut pas être vrai.
Parce que si ils faisaient tous les 3 partis de la tribu Vlog, alors aucun d'entre eux n'auraient pu l'avouer.
Puisque Vlog ment toujours.
Donc déjà, on sait que Alo est Vlog, de fait.
Et Menthe ne peut pas faire parti de la tribu Vlog par contre.
Parce que si il l'était, ça veut dire que Team serait le seul de la tribu Mental.
Et dans ce cas là, l'affirmation de Menthe serait vraie.
Ce qui ne pourrait pas être le cas si il faisait parti de la tribu Vlog, puisque chez les Vlog, on ment tout le temps.
Voilà ! Ça fait des petits nœuds au cerveau, mais c'est je trouve une énigme rigolote !
Mais peut-être pas autant que l'énigme du jour !
Énigme 31 ! L'avant dernière énigme.
Alors, je vous ai créé une énigme de logique. Je vais prendre un nom au hasard...
Sachez que ce nom ne reflète pas la vérité.
Évidemment !
Ah ! Le "évidemment" est un indice sur le nom que j'ai pris.
3 personnes parlent d'un Youtubeur.
Le premier dit: "Pierre est un Youtubeur très très riche. Il possède plus de 10 voitures."
"C'est complètement faux !" Répond le deuxième.
"Je suis certain qu'il a moins de 10 voitures."
Le troisième dit: "Écoutez, on va se détendre. Disons qu'il a au moins une voiture !"
Donc sachant qu'il n'y a qu'un seul des trois énoncés qui est vrai, combien Pierre a de voitures ?
Comme d'habitude, il n'y a pas d'embrouille, il y a une vraie réponse, qui vient d'une vraie logique,
qui nous permet d'avoir la vraie réponse, sûr et certain, à 100%
et de pouvoir expliquer pourquoi c'est la vraie réponse.
Quand vous avez trouvé la réponse, mettez juste "J'ai trouvé" dans les commentaires,
et un pouce en l'air pour qu'on puisse savoir le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la bonne réponse.
Mais n'écrivez pas la réponse en elle-même pour que les autres puissent continuer à chercher.
On le sait maintenant tout ça !
Demain c'est lundi, donc bon courage pour cette semaine pour ceux qui ont reprit le travail ou qui travaillent tout simplement.
Les autres, profitez de la fin des vacances !
Profitez de la fin de l'été !
Profitez en aussi pour vous abonner à la chaîne.
C'est important, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain pour la dernière énigme de cette série.
Ciao !